[Music]
today for our daily cancellation after
uh tackling some tough subjects on the
show there's nothing wrong with taking
the layup here um this is an easy one
though still worthy of the segment here
is a tick tock user who goes by the
handle little trans punk
explaining how your sexual attraction is
supposed to work trans punk
will tell you
who you are supposed to be attracted to
so this is his decision after all he's
trans punk he's the authority
listen to trans punk
all right i will assume that you asked
this question in the way that you really
want to learn so i will explain all the
ways that it is okay
let's say that you are attracted to
women well if you're attracted to a
woman then you're attracted to such
women trans women without bottom surgery
and trans women with
bottom surgery if you're attracted to
um bj then you could be attracted to a
cis moment a trans man without bottom
surgery or trans woman with bottom
surgery or
a non-binary person which depending on
their assigned gender at birth having or
not having had the surgery but it is
that exclusion that makes it
transphobic
so if you say that you like women and
you like dj
then that would mean that you're
attracted to cis women and trans women
who have had who have had bottom surgery
it is just that exclusion
that makes it transphobic you can have a
genital preference but to exclude trans
people is transphobic
ah so uh you see you know all that stuff
about how it's none of your business
what people do in the bedroom sexual
orientation isn't a choice anyone can
love whoever they want etc all of that
was nonsense of course well qualified
nonsense at least it's none of your
business what people do in the bedroom
but it is the business of trans punk and
his friends
you can't tell people who to love but
trans activists can
they can do all sorts of things that you
cannot do because they're special or so
they think
so a few points to make here first of
all of course um needless to say
what is a woman transpunce says that if
we're attracted to women we must also be
attracted to women with penises but
okay what does he think a woman is
he would probably say as they all do
that a woman is anybody who identifies
as a woman and that's a circular and
logically invalid definition
but it also raises questions about
sexual attraction so
when somebody says they're attracted to
women he thinks that
what they're attracted to is the woman's
self-perception
no attraction is defined the other way
if you're attracted to somebody you're
attracted based on your perception of
them not their perception of themselves
obviously
also you notice how the people who
lecture you for not being attracted to
them
seem to go out of their way to be
unattractive
they make themselves ugly and then blame
you for not finding them beautiful
they pierce their faces take on the
clown makeup and do everything in their
power to look as ridiculous as possible
and they scream in your face be
attracted to me you bigot
it's all a game
you know their ugliness becomes a test
of your wokeness
they make themselves into a sort of
left-wing hazing ritual
they paint their hair green they wear
their bizarre war paint and then they
tell you that you must sleep with them
in order to be initiated into the cult
because if you don't then you're
transphobic
which is why perhaps
a good response to this sort of thing
is to simply say
well okay
then i guess i'm transphobic
you're admitting that you're transphobic
you confess to the charge
sure
whatever fine
i don't care
the labels you use mean nothing to me
i'm not going to cower and tremble and
desperately try to prove my innocence to
you
i don't care if you think i'm guilty of
whatever category of crime you just made
up
i don't care how you see me
okay you have no power here
you can't manipulate me
you can't make me dance to this tune
you're playing
call me what you want doesn't matter
see in reality the term transphobia
means nothing it's a nonsense term
by design empty of meaning
so that they can go they can give it
whatever meaning they want in whatever
situation and now this person says that
transphobia means not being attracted to
him well
you made up the term so i guess you can
make up the definition and if that's the
definition not being attracted to you
then sure that's me guilty as charged
so now
we can now that we've established that
you're transphobic okay
sure whatever
so okay
that that's done
we can either move on and the
conversation can progress or you can sit
there babbling the word transphobia over
and over again while you curl into the
fetal position and rock yourself back
and forth it's up to you
the main point here is that just as we
discussed at the top of the show
they only have the power that we give
them
free yourself from the fear of being
labeled
labeled free yourself from any desire
to be accepted by the woke crowd
just let that go
and they will be totally disarmed
they will be reduced to sound and fury
signifying nothing
just as you can see in my film what is a
woman available now at whatiswoman.com
and that is all why our friend transpond
is today cancelled
hey listen
hit the subscribe button do it right now
i demand it and i thank you for your
compliance it is somewhat appreciated